[Music]
europe has long relied on natural gas to
power its cities fuel its factories and
heat its homes and in recent years about
40 percent of that gas came from russia
but this year europe is bracing for an
energy war
russia is deliberately cutting us
off we are working on
the worst possible scenario in recent
months russia has slashed gas flows
aiming an economic weapon at europe
now leaders are preparing for the
possibility that russian president
vladimir putin will keep gas flows at a
trickle or cut them off altogether to
try to gain leverage as he continues to
wage his war in ukraine so here's what
could happen and how it could affect you
whether you're in europe or not
first let's talk about a really
important pipeline the nordstream one
it runs under the baltic sea connecting
russia's prolific siberian gas fields to
germany europe's biggest economy
from there some of that gas is
re-exported to other european countries
even though there are other pipelines
sending gas from russia to europe the
nordstrom one handles about half of all
piped flows to the continent
back in june russia's state-owned gas
giant gazprom started reducing the gas
sent through the pipeline eventually
cutting exports by 60 percent and check
this out as flows were reduced you can
see that prices started to spike in
europe
russia essentially blamed western
sanctions for the slowdown pointing to a
turbine that was undergoing maintenance
in canada and got held up there but
several european leaders didn't buy that
explanation
all this is part of russia's strategy to
undermine our unity even though canada
ultimately agreed to return the turbine
western leaders began to worry that the
nordstrom one wouldn't reopen at full
capacity or even reopen it all when it
was closed for routine maintenance in
july a few of the analysts i talked to
say that's not some far-flung fear it's
looking like a real risk and they no
longer think that nordstrom oneflows
will return to normal
even if russia doesn't cut europe off
entirely and just sends less gas than
expected it'll still cause ripple
effects around the world
why
because european governments could be
forced to ration gas storage tanks are
typically filled during the summer but
they're already running low
and officials have begun urging citizens
to reduce their energy use and start
preparing for a tough winter
and companies are also bracing to get
hit hard since natural gas is used to
make everything from fertilizer and
glass to copper and cars
some manufacturers told the journal they
might be forced to make fewer products
or stop production altogether
a gas shortage would be particularly
painful for germany because it's a
manufacturing powerhouse that exports a
huge amount of our goods
and since it's the world's fourth
biggest economy what happens in germany
doesn't stay in germany economists
predict that europe would experience a
painful recession if russia tightens the
gas taps and no matter where you are in
the world you could feel the effects
think more supply chain headaches more
expensive goods steeper electricity
bills and potentially even higher
interest rates as countries grapple with
rising inflation
so how are european governments
responding
in the long term they're working to wean
themselves off of russian fossil fuels
altogether
but that process is expected to take
about five years so in the short term
they're scrambling to get ahead of a
winter crisis we need to make sure that
in case of full disruption
the gas flows towards where it's needed
most
in addition to deciding who would get
dibs on gas officials are scouring the
globe to strike gas deals in places like
azerbaijan norway and the us this chart
from the iea shows just how much europe
has turned toward liquefied natural gas
from the u.s in recent months june
marked the first month ever that the eu
imported more natural gas from the u.s
via ships than it did from russia via
pipeline
some european countries are also
restarting coal-fired plants and
reversing plans to close nuclear
reactors controversial steps that
leaders say are necessary
still the iea is warning that a looming
gas crunch poses a historic test for
europe and that europe must remain
united to get through it
so what does all of this mean for russia
russia has denied using gas to advance
its political goals and putin has blamed
western nations for rising prices
cutting gas to europe would be a
high-stakes move by moscow russia relies
on oil and gas sales for about 45
of the government's revenues and cutting
europe off would jeopardize russia's
standing as a reliable energy partner
plus it would force russia to depend
more on china
that's why many analysts think it's more
likely that russia will send a smaller
flow of gas to the continent instead of
cutting it off entirely that way russia
could capitalize on higher prices and
still deal a painful blow to europe
[Music]